buck you're a wanted man I don't do that
anymore the people who think you did or
not planning on taking a lot I know how
much Bucky means you
stay out of this one please you only
make this worse you know I can't that's
why I'm here if you can't accept
limitations
we're no better than bad guys you keep
telling yourself that
you know what's about to happen
do you really want to punch your way out
of this one
I'm sorry
but he's my friend
so was I
we're still friends right spends an
already at me
hey youtubers is charlie surprise
surprise even though there's so much DC
stuff going on they dropped new captain
america civil war footage most of it is
really taken from Captain America's
perspective it's other characters
talking to him about stuff he needs to
be doing stuff he needs to be worried
about why is the footage called hope if
not a single character says the word
hope in it the reason is because of that
Hawkeye black widows seen at the very
end where she's like we're still friends
right and he's like depends on how hard
you hit me if you remember in the first
Avengers movie when he was all whacked
out on the mind gem she just slammed his
head super hard in the trauma was what
brought him back to his senses so
there's kind of a double meaning when he
says depends on how hard you hit me like
when you're a little kid and you get
into a fight with your friend or your
brother yeah you might have a
disagreement you might punch each other
in the face a little bit there is hope
that you will be friends again very
quickly so that is why this footage is
called hope speaking of hope Chris Evans
is actually going to be dropping
completely different footage at the MTV
Movie Awards I think that's what it is
it's an MTV event on April 10th I'll
totally do a video for it but sometimes
MTV has weird rules about footage the
airs on its network so whatever it's
it's a ways away don't worry about it
the other really important footage you
may have noticed in this is a slightly
different framing of Tony Stark look at
the way he's talking to captain america
and look at the clothes that he's
wearing this is their costume designer
using clothing to tell the story of the
movie I know it sounds kind of silly but
there's this idea of composition like
you tell the story in the composition of
the film as well as in the dialogue like
you have Captain America disagreeing
with iron man we need to accept
limitations or we're no better than the
bad guys yeah keep telling yourself that
so imagine two people are having a
disagreement one of them is wearing a
very expensive three-piece suit the
other is dressed like an average person
who is the underdog in this situation
clearly you're meant to root for Captain
America and also iron man is sitting
down so a lot of times when they frame
two characters together the character
that sits higher and frame is typically
more powerful so even if you weren't
already team captain america this clip
is trying to inception you into thinking
that Captain America is in the right
here Iron Man is the antagonist and
that's assuming you haven't read comic
book Civil War if you've read the comics
you'll probably notice a lot of the
visual tricks that they'll play with the
movie just making Captain America seem
like the underdog
Tony Stark seemed like an [ __ ] but
the people that make the movies they've
read the comics so they do try to
introduce a couple clever twists so part
of the fun of seeing movies like this is
noticing all the visual tricks and then
looking for the twist that they
introduced with the comics especially
when it comes to big WTF desk the heap
teasing there's going to be some big
moment that's going to make fans poop
their pants and I feel like they're
going to kill one of the characters but
they're making it sound like Doctor
Strange is going to have the time gem so
you're like when we get to infinity war
does that mean that they're going to
reverse a lot of the damage that they've
done to themselves as well as the damage
that Thanos has done hard to tell I
think a lot of it depends on which
actors reup their contracts I love
thinking about how real world things
influence the plots of movies like Oh
so-and-so actor doesn't want to do the
franchise anymore well we need a big WTF
death okay why don't we use them we
could just kill them off that will
completely explain why their characters
and around anymore they also recut some
winter soldier scenes in this trailer
here it's like footage we've seen before
but it's done from a slightly different
perspective they make it sound like
somebody frames this big explosion on
Winter Soldier he says I don't really do
that stuff anymore so it's almost like
he's on walkabout trying to regain his
memories trying to remember who Bucky
Barnes is when this happens and they
come looking for him so maybe someone
like crossbones or someone behind Hydra
one of the villains of the movie pins
this on Winter Soldier and tries to use
that to pit the Avengers against each
other play on the fears of the world in
the wake of sokovia and all the crazy
things that have happened that the
Avengers have been involved in to
benefit from the chaos usually in the
comics when heroes go at each other like
in a civil war situation you find a
villain behind the scenes that's trying
to create that situation so that they
could benefit from the chaos so I'm
wondering who's going to emerge from the
shadows the rumor is is that Daniel
Bruhl is going to be one of the big
bones of the movie but that remains to
be seen I don't know if he's gonna wind
up being Baron Zemo I thought it was
confirmed at one point but people have
been saying that it's not confirmed so
we'll just have to wait and see now that
Batman V Superman is starting to die
down a little bit Captain America is
going to swell up there's going to be a
whole bunch of Captain America stuff in
the next month what I might do for my
next Civil War video is do something for
all the different people that have been
captain america besides Steve Rogers
there have been a bunch of different
people in the comics that have worn the
mantle so be sure to subscribe to get
that if there are any big Marvel videos
you guys want me to do just let me know
in the
there's some agents of shield there's
some Gotham stuff there's some other
little stuff that I'm trying to catch up
on especially daredevil too so some of
that my post to Facebook my next
daredevil video will probably post on
Wednesday or Thursday so don't worry
we'll get through all that stuff the
facebook page is facebook.com /
emergency awesome in my twitter is
awesome emergency so you guys can follow
me there for updates there is a new
episode of the flash posting tonight why
you guys wait for that you can click
here for my flash Supergirl crossover
video and you can click here to learn
all about the special Justice League
seat they just posted from Batman V
Superman there was just some deleted
footage that was actually a pretty big
deal thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you